eigentlich wollte ich heute ein video
hochladen ist morgen nerv eingeklemmt
zwei mal im bett gefallen und bei müll
rausbringen für den müll weiterhin
gefangen als tag auf dem boden
gleichheit dort von bio gedacht mit das
ist definitiv das dürfte wir hier
gesehen habe deswegen reagiert zusammen
drauf das eine komische betonung also
erst mal die kleine vorgeschichte wie
ich überhaupt dieses video gestoßen bin
ich direkt und videos durch gegangen so
ein bisschen durchgeschwitzt und dann
hat sich autorennbahn animiert und
normalerweise werde in dem video ist das
für ein scheiß ich meine wir analysieren
jetzt einfach mal die verschiedenen
teilnehmer dieses rennens fahren wir
dort einmal einen ketten legen dann
haben wir irgendwie einen schwarz
gefährten im typen drauf und noch drei
vier andere total komische menschen ich
finde vor allem auch wer sich wohl wie
ich fährt hier die ganze zeit läuft
genauso laufen nämlich stelle im video
etwas entscheidendes passiert und weil
wir achtmal aber irgendwie leute jetzt
komm ich nicht wie ich das kommentieren
würde als nächstes wieder eine
kontaktaufnahme von oben die wir jetzt
einen teil der macht sehen und merken
jetzt mal auf dieses pferd
[Applaus]
mitten im rennen steht ja auch einmal
von beim wert auf holt sich ein fettes
blatt papier und schwingt sich nach
hinten und ist wie ein drachen genau das
ist das ist auf jeden fall gut im rennen
zu gewinnen weiß jetzt noch nicht ganz
verstanden hat was der zielgerade ist
ich hab' ich habe euch verstanden
auf jeden fall den wir in der nächsten
szene wieder eine aufnahme von oben aus
der vogelperspektive und teilnehmer
jetzt denkt sich so das mittlere weiße
pferd in der wiese ist das wäre
eigentlich so lange fährt bzw die
reiterinnen darauf was ist das für ein
scheiß jetzt denkt man sich vielleicht
sogar komplett normal leiterin danach
die länger geworden und danach gegen die
hoch gegangen immer hoch und runter da
denkt man sich beim ok
das kann jetzt nicht dümmer werden
geputzt und fliegt in den himmel und es
weg überhaupt macht vielleicht sehen wir
am ende das wieder und jetzt kommt nur
noch stelle im rennen bzw
im video da erinnert sich jetzt gerade
alles ist ja eigentlich ja gesagt
pferderennen das erhofft ich werde mit
am start und hat irgendwie so ein yeti
oder irgendwann zu verlieren sondern die
ganze zeit schon dieses pferd gesehen
und dieses pferd sieht ja nicht so aus
als wäre wirklich ein echtes wert also
acht mir doch wieder kehrt und schauen
was dort wirklich sich ein darunter
befindet und was danach passieren was
die taktik
der gewohnte fand mit pferde macht ein
elefant mit pferden machte hat nicht
unter diesem wert versteckt und gewinnt
das rennen also häuser da muss ich echt
sagen ab laut an den elefanten fährt in
der rätseln viele sehen wir die ganzen
anderen teilnehmer das rennen ihr die
ziellinie überqueren und unser fährt was
vorhin durch den kurs nach oben geflogen
jetzt kommt auch tatsächlich auch für
sich entscheiden konnte wie gesagt
wollte heute eigentlich gar kein video
machen weil die ganze zeit
bachelorarbeit geschrieben habe und ich
hab mir nerv eingeklemmt man sah ich ein
kunstwerk geworden dann habe ich dieses
video gesehen und dachte mir einfach
wenn euch das video häufige fahrrad dann
lasst ihr einmal will ich nicht während
freunde findet jetzt hier oben einem
eingebildeten könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren
das passte keine videos mehr und macht
euch automatisch zu einem besseren
menschen da oben findet auch ein shop
eingeblendet und hier wohnten ist ein
weiteres video verlinkt